it's great to see you guys today you're
doing a tremendous job and may i say
right off the bat
pierce it's great to have you out of
that evil cnn
and back where you belong in london and
the beautiful susanna
i am going to reinstitute reinstitute
my beauty pageants because you look
tremendous today
johnny you reigned for years as king
of talk show hosts well now we're
talking
what was the secret of your success
you know jimmy i'd love to answer that
but i don't work on mondays
hold on son wait a minute baby nobody
comes back here
oh i'm tired of eating squirrel son oh
larry this is not about me it's about
the american people
plain and simple but it's your party so
aren't you gonna be the candidate
larry why do you make assumptions that's
just propaganda
now we're going to have all kinds of
candidates i'll just be one we're going
to have regular
american folks running for president
we're going to have all kinds
midgets crack [ __ ] everything you can
think of
hey uh hey what are you looking at but
ed hey why don't you make like a tree
and get out of here
you know that that is a great line
everything is so great
the stuff you guys are doing with the
50s and everything
no i had jackets like this can you
believe that i'm the old guy you know
you need to see because
santa's important and if you can't see
then you then you
then you don't know what you're looking
at
oh yes thank you yes tell us a guy
sitting at home going what the hell
going on there yes there's a kid going
that's not the way yes then he's like
martha graham i think man ball and chain
and kicking button
yes thank you uh i'm in
magic money magic
magic my magic my
whole bunch of naked people walking
around
if your wife hasn't been laid of course
she's gonna go and see it either out of
50 shades of grey
take my wife please take her
no no i'm only pulling
i i i love my wife but
she don't know how to cook her cooking
is so bad
is terrible if i walk into this
kitchen and i see
a cantaloupe on that table
i will lose my mind
hello america
[Applause]
and those of you from nantucket
that was back there and all i'm talking
about
listen here's the thing steve uh
his thing uh swear to god um
listen steve the fact is i
listen i do every movie steve i'm
everywhere
listen it's me dwayne johnson and meryl
streep swear to god that's all you get
and i mean
it's just that ba ba ba ba ba can't keep
a good man down
can you brush kenya
you look at me when i'm talking to you
son
hi shaq how are you i'm good
[Laughter]
um i see you doing a lot of commercials
these days you know i've played a long
time in basketball it's one of the most
diverse sites
gonna have a lot of fun doing the
commercials obviously you're like oh
y'all know all my commercials but
i've always been a renaissance man yeah
yeah jim brewer and and these guys have
got all these great impressions you know
so i i said
oh i gotta learn some impressions so are
you guys already this
this is my newest impression of these
not a lot of it because here's uh
ed sullivan and i'm like he's really
gonna do ed
sullivan like why would ever
celebrate introducing the beatles
because ladies and gentlemen it's the
beatles
well i gotta work on that a little bit
listen this ain't even a hold on fam
because because look this is the real
what we're not gonna do is you know you
ain't gonna put me
in no for focus that's not gonna happen
my name is dwayne the rock johnson
known as the champ here doing
trump has a very similar voice you know
it's wonderful that we're here in new
york stone i want to show you some real
estate while we're up here
own it own it own it own it own it own
it and own it and that one i sold to
a japanese conglomerate and they took a
bath on it that was a very good deal
now now the way i understand it dr
kane said that miss marple said that the
knife that was found in the back of sir
reginald
was the same knife that was used in the
kitchen by the maid winnie annie that
originally belonged to the gardener ben
harper used
to scrape
i'm john mulaney i'm on jimmy kimmel and
i'm
loving it it's amazing
we do go to war i can assure you it will
not be another
vietnam because we have learned well the
simple lesson of vietnam
stay out of vietnam
seth let me start by saying i have
nothing against
guns and i'm not just saying that
because i look like a bullet
my name is morgan freeman
and i have been talking like this since
i was just a
young boy i gotta say i gotta say this
why
why did it take so long that's my
question that should have been had me in
austin
you seen me y'all seen
kevin how are you nice to see you oh
shut up
like dave they like it i worked on
something
just for this moment
okay i had to write it down
[Music]
here it is
uh uh i said denzel we got the mariachi
band coming for he said oh my reality
all right
okay okay all right mariachi
so you go
[Applause]
who dares bother the all in powerful
wizard of oz
oh my god incredibly wonderful place
[Applause]
madonna connor where's the ass come on
but i turned on the inside it was
amazing it's wonderful
cause i met up with the guy who's made
of the straw i said hey man whoa hey man
straw that's a joke right there
hi
trick or treat
[Applause]
that's a damn good question
trick trade quite the conundrum
having said that my young costumed
friends
as fade would have it i too have a
question
which one of your little kids can guess
what i've buried under my house
hey kids yo everybody just needs to like
chill you know i mean like listen like
chill
like you know there's like a lot of
stuff happening okay i know what you're
trying to say but this is what i'm
trying to say
black lives matter huh
i can't believe i ate the whole thing
all my friends were saying mean things
hurt my feelings shack a big strong man
outside
what's off inside shaq hate bullets
everyone is calling shaq dumb but shaq
not dumb
i have a doctorate charles is a dumb one
charles probably think dr redd is a girl
doctor
shaka boy doctor he said i went over
there he made me pranks
yeah boyfriends it that's why i'ma
always be cool with eddie cause he may
be them franks
and when i was young they used to call
me fat murphy
i know the the that you know
that that i know that that that you know
and if you knew that i knew that
then then then we both would know if
if renewed all that carpet
the way it goes from wall to wall
just doing what it does multiple colors
and
i walk on you sweet carpet
oh no it's real simple dave that's real
simple
all i got to do is let go of the
illusion that i exist
drive around in my lincoln
roll in this booger
[Applause]
hey what's up man all right cool good to
see you rock
all right what we got here what we got
here okay we got overturned shop we got
a shot right here okay
hey oh oh no
son that costs 200 dollars
i should have got a goldfish well not no
jimmy i i
i know what you're saying i'm aware of
what you're trying to say
and the answer is yes
did you see the interview that shaq did
right after they won the championship
the dude that was interviewing him was
more excited than he was
so shocked how do you feel i feel good
i just want to thank my mother i think
my father never got it making sure
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what i i do this one but i
never talk about it
i do jason statham and i say i'm the
transporter and what i will do
i'll punch you in the face and have sex
with me girl right on top of your course
jay i noticed that your dog was in here
a moment ago
has no tail that's crazy this is
president obama reacting to donald
trump's entrance of the rnc
uh who do you think you are uh you ate
the rock
i'm borough do you smell lulla
what barack is cooking uh what do you
want morgan well i've been thinking
about this for quite a while
not really sure what i want let's see a
big mac quarter pounder with cheese
let's see one of the others so just like
him
believe it or not that's what i do let's
see
let's just go with fries
when you come out you're very flowy and
very high pitched
and very uh going and you're on and
you're looking
and you're seeing and you're sexy and
unbuttoned and fantastical
dave who want to go to africa africans
don't even want to go to africa
and they live there
when there's something strange
in your neighborhood
who are you gonna call
that's right ghostbusters so uh what i
need you to do is uh
you know uh take it off and uh
i'll put a nouveau ring on it i don't
know i don't know
i don't know whatever stop well
basically this is your voice
i don't know how you feel about it but i
don't even know
if it's that good but this is the voice
it's halloween a lot of people are
dressing up of course as ghosts and
witches and
gobblers and vampires but this year i've
decided i'm going
as the scariest creature in the world my
ex-wife
if they look under the seas they're
probably going to get a copy of 444.
who the hell are you
you know i had a pretty good career
considering the fact that i didn't even
finish college
and a reporter over at the times found
out about this
and he asked me point blank he said mr
president
were you a dropout i said what
he said were you a dropout i said no
no i i was cesarian
[Applause]
i'm so sexy look at my ass another day
another 50 000.
sound like they [ __ ] puff the magic
dragon
uh huffed and puffed and then
kept puffing and puff some more and then
he like got some oreos with his friends
why please
[Applause]
a home run and a triple a first
baseman's glove a catcher's glove
and dolly parton
[Applause]
name two big hits two big mets
second trades
smell my feet
give me something good to eat
physical just you know how lebron yeah
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so sometimes you know you might hear me
talking like arnold schwarzenegger
a lot of people think that when you talk
like arnold you have to go
arnold doesn't talk like that dennis
murphy has this real kind of sing-song
way
but he always gets things he's like an
old kind of news reporter we always get
stories about like young kids like
murdering each other or something
so i'll be like you know katie and cara
were bffs
because they had just bought the new
future album that had just dropped
and they were smoking kush and twerking
[Music]
[Music]
but when a willing victim who has
committed no treachery
is killed and a traitor
stone taken
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]